90 soldats français sont morts dans
cette opération depuis 20 ans pourquoi
3,5 milliards d'euros ont été investis
pour quoi pourquoi sommes nous allés là
bas derrière les etats unis à aucun
moment la stratégie mise en place par
nos partenaires américains a été
véritablement questionner
[Musique]
votre propos m devrait être cadré que
tout ça est un échec terrible
retentissant et pourtant beaucoup
d'éléments amené à penser que c'est vers
l'échec que nous allions donc il faudra
tirer des leçons parce que des hommes
sont morts parce que des moyens publics
ont été investis et parce qu'il ya là
sans doute quelque chose qui peut se
reproduire demain
[Musique]
et la question qui a été posée c'est
aussi qui avons-nous combattu au cours
de ces années avec une remarque laissant
entendre que peut-être nous aurions
sacrifier des vies
investi des moyens publics en pure perte
je m'inscris tout à fait en faux contre
cela monsieur le député
nos militaires n'ont pas donné leur vie
pour rien
[Musique]